AJA HAMMERLY: In
this Cloud Minute,
I'll show you how to export
logs from Stackdriver Logging
into Cloud Storage,
BigQuery, or Pub/Sub.
Exporting logs to cloud storage
allows you to store them
for extended periods of time.
Exporting to BigQuery allows you
to do more complicated analysis
of your logs.
And exporting Pub/Sub
allows you to send your logs
to other applications.
From the Stackdriver logs
viewer, click on Create Export.
You can limit your export
by using the logging filters
if you need to.
Now you need to name your sync.
You can use alphanumeric
characters, underscore dash,
and period.
Now it's time to
select a service.
If you choose Cloud
Storage, you'll
be asked to pick
a storage bucket.
If you choose BigQuery, you'll
be asked to choose a data set.
Now click Create Sync.
Logs exported to BigQuery will
show up almost immediately.
Logs exported to Cloud Storage
are batched and will show up
approximately once an hour.
Now I can use the
power of BigQuery
to look deeper into my logs.